on commence à
manquer il est 20h30 dehors la
température ressentie est de -26
andréens et valérie de la maison benoît
labre sillonnent les rues du sud-ouest
à la recherche de personnes en situation
d'itinérance café
les intervenantes entre dans le métro
monk cherche des visages connus
valérie les rejoint pour voir si elle
peut porter assistance
pelli elle laisse donc les policiers à
intervenir pour se rendre sur le quai du
métro
elle réveille une vieille dame
visiblement pas une habituée de la rue
valérie lui demande si elle veut aller
dans une halle de chaleur elle refuse
elle ne se sent pas en sécurité dans ces
endroits mais elle ira demain à la
maison benoît labre
l'équipe se rend à l'édicule pour voir
craig en plein show
pour se réchauffer il flâne c'est
pourquoi la maison benoît labre demande
à la ville de montréal d'ouvrir certains
édicules de métro par temps froid des
navettes comme celle ci ou celle là il
en existe moins d'une dizaine à montréal
géré par différents organismes on arrive
à de 15h à 23h pour la petit nice mais
faudrait que ça soit doublé la ville de
montréal offre plus de 1900 places en
hébergement d'urgence cette année un
record si le manque de lits c'est
davantage dû à un manque de main
d'oeuvre selon le cias du centre-sud
j'ai dû passer le chiffre de 9,5 fin mai
du train ça inclut déjà les places
seront dédiées à la cause du don un
compas disparu
320 places 350 perte de ces nitrates ont
été trompés sur la cohésion
s'est mis à jour à 18 h au son des
chansons
ils doivent donc survivre d'or par froid
glacial le problème au niveau des
hébergements d'urgence ça date pas
d'hier il n'y a pas assez de lits à
montréal malgré ce que madame plantes
c'est comme si tu as à dire dans les
médias ne pas être là samedi soir en une
heure mais qui pas approcher neuf
personnes or refuge
ici marie josée paquet comme ou radio
canada montréal